is President from Tehran strategy
strategy or just chaos plus president
from changes his mind on ice rates and
Democrats get even more radical I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
right well we have a lot of news to get
to also later in the hour I will regale
you with the antics of my children
during my wife's graduation ceremony
yesterday yeah I know I'm gonna put you
through that but don't worry we'll save
it for the end of the show but first
will you fight for your freedom every
week it seems I bring you a new story
about attacks on religious freedom and
free speech I mean this is stuff that I
truly care about right as a religious
person one of the things that I worry
most about in the state of California is
the state cracking down on religious
practice well we're starting to see this
all over the country from the radical
left dr. David Schwartz is an Orthodox
Jewish psychotherapist New York enacted
a law it censors speech between
therapist and client by prohibiting
treatment of clients who struggle with
same-sex attraction or gender dysphoria
like the client comes in and just once
to be helped dr. Schwartz could be
punished with fines of up to $10,000 per
offense just for helping them the way
they want to be helped this type of case
is why Alliance defending freedom exists
ATF provides free legal services to dr.
Schwartz and others whose freedoms are
under assault but ATF can't provide
these resources without your help ATF
relies on donations to fight for your
freedom if this attack can happen to
somebody like dr. Schwartz it could
happen to you I think this stuff is some
of the most important this may be the
most important fight in America
seriously will you fight for dr.
Schwartz and protect your freedom please
give generously all donations are
tax-deductible if you donate 75 bucks
and above you receive an exclusive free
speech shirt go to ATF legal org slash
pen to donate right now
that's ATF legal org slash been helped
to support dr. Schwartz and protect all
of our freedoms because if they can do
it to him they can do it to you and they
will they're gonna come after all of us
but not if ATF stands between them and
us
that's ATF legal org slash pen please
donate they're a great great
organization okay so we begin today with
the latest on the tension with Iran
so before we get to the actual latest on
the tension with Iran there's a really
great piece by Michael Doran who's a
senior fellow at Hudson Institute and he
goes through what exactly a Ron is
trying to do here and it's it's
necessary to understand what Iran is
trying to do and what the United States
is trying to accomplish to determine
what the strategy should be
with regard to Iran now listen the
backdrop here is that nobody really
knows in foreign policy it's not it's
not a machine nobody knows in foreign
policy what can happen given any
circumstance foreign policy is simply
too unpredictable
there are however tried-and-true
strategies when it comes to things like
deterrence if you're trying to deter
somebody's action they have to know that
you are committed to taking a very harsh
step should they violate a line right
this is why President Obama violating
his own red line in Syria was so
devastating it's why when President
Obama said to Syria used chemical
weapons and that will violate our
redline and then him backing off the red
line and undermined his credibility and
it led to tremendous suffering across
the Middle East and across the world
it's one of the reasons why a lot of a
lot of America's enemies got more
ambitious and more aggressive in the
face of President Obama in other words
the the talk softly and carry a big
stick methodology of Teddy Roosevelt
isn't just a nice phrase it's also a
very good strategy that when you carry
the stick people should know that you're
carrying the stick blustering is not
good bluffing is not good if you're
gonna draw a red line it actually has to
be a red line and if you're not gonna
draw a line a red line then don't draw a
red line be very clear about where your
lines are so that people know that if
they cross them you're gonna smack them
that is sort of the the predicate to
this discussion we have to know what
exactly the policy is and the policy has
to be backed by an actual grand strategy
it can't just be haphazard it can't be
you're frustrated so you throw a missile
somewhere the Clintonian policy of an
embassy gets bombed in Kenya or Tanzania
and so we toss some missile at a drug
Factory in Sudan you can't actually do
that right now that that doesn't event
any sort of fear on the part of your
enemies or the belief in consistency
foreign policy is a lot more like
parenting when the United States is
involved than it is like a bargain
between mutual friends there is no
community of nations when it comes to
the international community there's no
community the international community is
a dog-eat-dog space and that means that
the most powerful hand the whip hand in
America in international politics has to
be very printable and very solid people
have to know what they are going to do
before they do it especially if they're
going to take a strong policy okay so
what exactly does Ron want because right
now ron has been engaged in aggressive
the antics for the past several months
well Michael Doran as I says is a really
good
over at mosaic it's called what Iran is
really up to
they say he says in April 2015 the joint
comprehensive plan of action the jcpoa
that is the Iran nuclear deal signed by
President Obama a garbage deal was still
to be formalized the Republicans
preparing to run for president in the
following year were already denouncing
it at a public forum in New York City
The Washington Post columnist David
Ignatius asked revoir Zarif the Iranian
Foreign Minister whether he worried that
one of these Republicans if elected
might overturn the deal Zarif answered
confidently any successor to Barack
Obama would be constrained by
international law by America's
commitments formal and informal to
allies and partners and by all the norms
that governed relations among nations
today he said I believe the United
States will risk isolating itself in the
world if there's an agreement and it
decides to break it the result of any
such action he predicted would be chaos
cerise comments as Doran prefigured the
strategy that Iran's supreme leader Ali
Khamenei is following today in his
brinksmanship with President Trump
playing on the fear especially prevalent
among European elites in American
Democrats that Trump is precisely an
agent of chaos Khomeini has taken a leaf
from the book of Chinese leader Xi
Jinping who in 2017 appeared at the
World Economic Forum as the
representative of enlightened globalism
we should adhere to multilateralism to
uphold the authority and efficacy of
multilateral institutions she declared
we should honor promises and abide by
rules the Court struck by she we're
still resonating in the halls of the g20
summit in Buenos Aires last December
when the assembled leaders adopted a
joint communique communique affirming
their commitment to a rules-based
international order this is shorthand
for slapping Trump presumably Khomeini
intends to leverage the fears that haunt
Europeans by raising the specter of war
and simultaneously offering a
cooperative multilateral way to exercise
it namely by returning America to the
Iran nuclear deal his goal is to place
president Trump's renunciation of the
Iran nuclear deal on the unofficial
agenda of this week's g20 summit which
begins Saturday June 29th and 30th in
the hope that it will win a place on the
short list of from major sins against a
rules-based international order right up
there with the American president's
economic protectionism and his disavowal
of the Paris climate a core so basically
what Himani wants is to get the
Europeans to pressure President Trump in
to resigning the Iran nuclear deal why
because the Iran nuclear deal allows
Iran to develop a new clue
weapon as I'll explain in just a second
rather as Michael Doran explains over at
Mosaic and this is exactly right I'll
explain in just one second first you
know the big tech companies are looking
for all your data they want your data
because then they monetize your Zeta and
that's annoying to you because you
didn't think that's really what they
were doing but here's the truth big tech
companies making gobs and gobs your
money well you can do that too if you
want to keep giving them your data you
can go right ahead and do that but you
should know that you too can be earning
money off your own Zeta with big tokens
so here's how it works first you
download the app and you sign up for a
free big token account next you complete
actions to earn points actions include
answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more then you can redeem
your points for rewards like cash and
gift cards you can donate your earnings
to charity you choose what data you
share with big token and then you get
paid for it your data is always secured
in big token the best part is you're
gonna get paid if you want to start
earning money for your data go to the
App Store or Google Play
search for big token that's b.i.g tok
and big token that's one word download
the app and sign up make sure to use my
referral code Shapiro again search big
token in the App Store or Google Play
download the app use my referral code
Shapiro to sign up claim your data get
paid go check them out right now big
token in the App Store or at Google Play
why should everybody else make money on
your data when you could be making money
on your data go check them out and use
my referral code Shapiro to sign up ok
back to the strategy that Iran is using
here so according to Michael Doran he
says it was the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani who revealed the public face of
the new strategy the date May 8th was
highly symbolic exactly one year earlier
to the day Trump had renounced the
nuclear deal and reimpose sanctions on
Iran his country's patience rouhani
declared in a televised speech was
exhausted for 12 months Iran had
displayed admirable forbearance in the
face of Trump's maximum pressure
campaign against it and had done so he
said in an obvious nod to the Europeans
in large part because nameless
signatories to the Iran nuclear deal had
asked to her on to avoid acts of
retaliation while they work to help
shelter it from the worst ravages of
American sanctions rouhani said this
strategic patience indicates the Iranian
nations power and greatness now notice
that rouhani is actually using the same
language here that Barack Obama used
about Iran Barack Obama suggested that
the strategy with strategic patience and
now rouhani is saying that he is using
strategic patience against Trump
in other words the rogue
here is not Iran the rogue actor is
Trump according to the Iranian regime
but now they're going to give way to
strategic pressure according to rouhani
Iran would cease to observe the
restrictions the nuclear deal placed on
its stockpiles of heavy water and
enriched uranium on June 17th the
spokesman of Iran's Atomic Energy
organization followed up disclosing that
Iran's stockpiles were set to exceed the
jcpoa limits in 10 days just in time for
the g20 summit around in other words
would have to break the deal in order to
save it they were basically trying to
push the European saying listen we're
gonna break the deal we're gonna go full
nuclear unless you reinstate the Iran
nuclear deal and pay us off and they
were going to increase the pressure in
order to generate a feeling of chaos
such that the Europeans would pressure
President Trump to sign up to an
agreement again that is the goal here
the goal here is to get the is to get
the Europeans to basically undercut
president Trump and to undercut
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and to
undercut the Trump administration's
getting out of the Iran nuclear deal
according to the prevailing view what
pushed Iran over the edge and
precipitated rouhani's May 8th speech
was the Trump administration's decision
in April to cite tighten economic
sanctions that were seriously affecting
the Islamic Republic's ability to sell
its oil but this view overlooks
something else on May 3rd Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo revoked two waivers
that had been allowing Iran to ship
heavy water to Oman and low enriched
uranium to Russia
when ruhani announced five days later
that Iran would cease complying with the
jcpoa restrictions on enriched uranium
and heavy water he was reacting directly
to Mike Pompeo May 3rd revocation of the
two waivers Iran's policy of strategic
pressure then says Mike Duran this is
really good peace is made up of three
separate but interlocking lines of
effort one a struggle to gain relief
from the oil and banking sanctions 2 a
campaign to tarnish president Trump as
an agent of chaos and 3 an initiative
aimed at keeping its nuclear waivers in
place among these the third is by far is
by far the most important so what are
these waivers well apparently there are
a bunch of waivers that permit the
Europeans to cooperate with the Iranians
on projects permitted under the terms of
the Iran nuclear deal there are seven
sets of such waivers in total
Pompeyo has revoked only the two that
pertain to the export of enriched
uranium and heavy water but the other
five remain in force now there are
people
inside the Trump administration who say
we should end all the waivers and that
would dramatically put pressure on the
Iranian economy but they're also people
in the State Department who didn't want
that kind of pressure on the Europeans
the Europeans were lobbying Washington
to Canoe continue renewing all of the
waivers and those efforts were partially
successful the five waivers escaped the
acts because they applied to activities
in which Iran's partners are European
presumably the Europeans kept on
well-informed regarding the debate in
Washington Khomeini understands that the
Europeans are fighting hard to save the
nuclear deal and that their support is
an asset to Iran and that the debate
over the waivers has also been creating
in the transatlantic alliance a fissure
that benefits Iran he also understands
that the fight is by no means over the
administration usually grants waivers
180 days on May 3rd its shortened the
term to 90 days Khomeini is intent on
pressuring the Europeans and interested
powers like Japan to convince the
American president to reinstate the to
revoked waivers and commit his
administration's leaving the other five
in place for the remainder of his term
in office
also the Trump administration has been
considering whether to activate the
multilateral snapback mechanism at the
UN meaning that there was a mechanism
that was supposed to be in place during
the Iran nuclear deal that if the
Iranians violated the agreement the
sanctions would snapback and there's
enough information to show that the
Iranians have violated the nuclear deal
because there are archives showing that
Iran never abandon its nuclear weapons
program but simply restructured it
emphasizing dual use activities to allow
Tehran's who falsely claimed that they
are pursuing peaceful nuclear activities
if Trump were to invoke the snapback
then a bunch of sanctions would be put
back into place so coming he must
instead push the idea that he has been
abiding by the deal that the waiver
should stay in place and that as
president Trump puts new pressure the
possibilities of chaos are increasing so
this is the game is the game and he's
being helped out in this game by
Democrats so Democrats have been jumping
on the bandwagon Europeans have been
jumping on the bandwagon as well the
press have been jumping on the bandwagon
proposing that it's president Trump who
seriously wants war now there's no
evidence that President Trump wants war
in fact Trump keeps saying over and over
and over again that he does not in fact
want war right here's President Trump
over
weekend explaining that everyone was
saying I'm a warmonger now they're all
saying I'm a dub so what's the deal
everybody was saying I'm a warmonger and
now they say I'm a dove and I think I'm
neither you want to know the truth
I'm a man with common sense and that's
what we need in this country is common
sense but I didn't like the idea of them
knowingly shooting down an unmanned
drone and then we kill 150 people I
didn't like that
okay Maxine Waters rank comes out and
she is actually doing the work of the
Iranian administration she tweets out
Trump you get no credit for so-called
stopping the strike against Iran
why was the unmanned drone in Iran's
airspace it wasn't why the surveillance
because you have to surveil
international airspace don't provoke and
then pretend innocence so everybody is
jumping on the Iranian bandwagon here I
mean it this is pretty astonishing so
basically you have a bunch of people in
the Democratic Party who made a deal
with the Iranian regime and then blame
the Republicans saying the Republicans
are trying to undercut the deal and this
helped Iran's hardliners that was an
absolute lie the Iranian hardliners are
the government hey now you have the
Iranian government which is stumping for
Kaos specifically in order to undercut
Trump and Democrats are signing up for
the party you have folks like Adam
Schiff who are suggesting that it's
Trump's chaos in the Middle East even
though he knows that it's Iran you have
people like Maxine Waters overtly
parroting Iranian propaganda that's
what's going on here now in a second
we're gonna get to president Trump's
actual strategy here because here's the
problem this is a point where you do
need a certain level of stability you
need the president's strategy to be out
there you need him to explain his
strategy people have to know where the
lines are where he is willing to bend
where he is not willing to bend because
otherwise the Iranians have an interest
in upping the ante if as I suggest the
Iranians are interested in chaos then
forward in chaos would seem to be what
they are looking for okay so here is
President Trump's policy so according to
The Wall Street Journal President Trump
ended up bucking his national security
aides on his own proposed Iran attack
they say presidents from most of
his top national security advisors by
abandoning retaliatory strikes in Iran
on Thursday in private conversations on
Friday
Trump reveled in his judgment certain
about his decision to call off the
attacks while speaking of his
raishin as if removed from the center of
it Trump told one confidants about his
own inner circle of advisers quote these
people want to push us into a war and
it's so disgusting we don't need any
more Wars now again I disagree with that
on a fundamental level I don't think
that Secretary of State Mike Pompeo was
itching for war with Iran I don't think
that john bolton is itching for war with
iran despite all of the talk about this
I really don't in the notion that these
folks are just desperate to go to a war
that would end with tens of thousands of
American dead presumably and billions if
not trillions of dollars spent nobody is
interested in that but one of the ways
that you prevent war is you prevent
international misunderstanding that
escalates into war because here's two
ways of falling into war way number one
the United States reacts to an Iranian
provocation and then the Iranians try to
pancake a bunch of American bases and
then we're in a war okay because we were
too harsh in our response way number two
is that we aren't harsh in our response
Iran keeps pushing the envelope to the
point where we have no choice
Iran shoots down a man's American
aircraft Iran takes captures a bunch of
American soldiers Iran kills an American
now President Trump has said if they do
that then we're gonna have to do
something okay well you got to set the
lines because the Iranians are gonna
push right up to the line whatever the
line is the Iranians are gonna push all
the way up to it and if you don't make
clear what the line is if you have a
secret line in your head and the
Iranians violate it you can find
yourself in a war much more easily than
if you say here is the line you cross it
and the hammer comes down right now it's
not clear where president Trump's line
is because he keeps moving around on the
line and listen maybe there's a strategy
in place but it would be good to hear it
it would be good to hear what the
strategy is because the Iranians clearly
have a strategy and that is to play on
the sense of chaos inside the Trump
administration to convince the Europeans
to pressure Trump to make a deal and for
them to appeal to Trump's isolationist
side because here's what the Iranians
are gonna do now what the Iranians are
going to do is they're going to go to
the Europeans and they're gonna say to
the Europeans Oh Trump's an agent of
chaos you need to get him back in this
Iran nuclear deal we can go back to
status quo ante under the Iran nuclear
deal and everything will be all better
and that chaotic Trump will be taken off
the table and then where are you gonna
get our Europeans and isolationists in
the United States who go to president
from and say you don't need a war man
and the best thing you can do here is do
exactly what you did with NAFTA which is
you can sign
that looks a lot like Iran nuclear deal
but call it Trump steel and then get all
the credit and that's sort of an
appealing pitch to president Trump now
this rests on what do you think
America's interests are really in the
end this restaurant what do you think
America's interests are in the region
part of the problem for President Trump
is I'm not sure that he really believes
America has significant interests in the
region
he keeps signaling back and forth so on
the one hand he says that we have an
interest in Iran not gaining a nuclear
weapon okay well if that's true Ron's
been violating the nuclear deal so the
sanctions should stay in place on the
other hand when they are shooting ships
and blowing them up in the in the
Straits of Hormuz the president seems
unconcerned about that so here's the
president tweeted today quote China gets
91 percent of its oil from the Strait
Japan 62 percent and many other
countries likewise so why are we
protecting the shipping lanes for other
countries many years for zero
compensation all of these countries
should be protecting their own ships on
what has always been a dangerous journey
we don't need to be there in that the US
has just become by far the largest
producer of energy anywhere in the world
the u.s. request for Ron is very simple
no looting no nuclear weapons and no
further sponsoring of terrorism but
here's the reality when it comes to no
further sponsoring of terrorism who
knows what the president Trump is really
committed to Iran not sponsoring
terrorism in the region why should we
care and for the same reason that he
doesn't seem to care about the Strait of
Hormuz why should we care if Iran is
sponsoring a war in Yemen that's a very
far away place and this sort of Tucker
Carlson's point over the weekend the
truth is however in international
politics there is no such thing as a
vacuum so let's say that the United
States were to pull out of the Gulf of
Oman and the Straits of Hormuz let's say
we're just gonna pull out right now and
China where's you take control because
it's a lot of Chinese well that is going
through and trying to were to work with
Iran do you think that that's beneficial
for the United States for China to
control a significant amount of the
world's oil supply the fact is that we
have a global oil market so while the
United States may be self-sufficient in
terms of oil the amount of oil that we
put on the market has a heavy impact on
what the price of oil is at the pump in
1973 when the when OPEC decided on an
oil embargo against the United States
the United States was still a solid
producer of oil yeah but it does impact
the global oil prices and the price at
the pump if in fact the
other players in the global market
decide that they are going to shut down
key shipping lanes like the Straits of
Hormuz so when the United States
retreats from the world scene that is
not left open and that it also
encourages the threat of violence in the
end because you strengthen China the
president Trump is very concerned I
think rightly so at the global ambitions
of the Chinese he's rightly concerned at
the strength of China's government and
China's territorial ambitions so would
the goal be to hand over the Straits of
Hormuz to me that's no better than
Vladimir Putin taking control of Syria
we have geopolitical rivals those
geopolitical rivals are interested in
taking more territory under their own
control and then providing threats to
America's national security as well as
to America's partners and allies as well
as to global trade and economics if you
believe the global economics is entirely
global indeed it's a global thing the
United States has an interest in
preserving the freedom of economics and
the freedom of flow of things like oil
if you believe that there are rival
countries out there that have
territorial ambitions and want to form
alliances with evil countries like Iran
in order to forward those ambitions and
that as those countries gain power they
become more threatening to the United
States you got a problem now listen you
can air on the other side too right you
can air on the other side of looking to
go to pre-emptive war every five minutes
because you think that you see a threat
around every corner and can do that too
and we ought to be cautious we ought to
be cautious I think one thing that we
learned from the debacle in terms of
intelligence in Iraq is that we ought to
be cautious about these things obviously
but there's also a point to be made
which is if you can take an action that
forestalls the growth of an alliance
against you at a cheap cost meaning you
knock out Iran's Navy for example and
Iran isn't going to go to full war if
that's the analysis then maybe that's
something you got to say to them right
now we don't seem to have a strategy and
president Trump well he may have been
right not to strike the Iranians over
the downing of the drone I said last
week I think that he was wrong maybe
he's right maybe he's right whatever it
is it has to be part of a broader
strategy because if it really is just
gut level we're doing it or not doing it
that's going to allow Iran exactly what
they want which is to grant this feeling
of Kass now maybe you're a full
isolationist you think we should pull
out of the region entirely you don't
care if Iran takes control of the Strait
of Hormuz you don't care if China gets
involved you don't care if the Rush
gain power you think that the United
States should basically retreat within
its own borders and then leave the world
as is I think that's bad foreign policy
I think that that's a mistaken foreign
policy because the fact is either the
United States occupies the space or our
enemies occupy the space and if we can
do so at low cost we ought to occupy the
space because if we don't we will have
to defend that space at much higher cost
in the future but we have to decide on
what the vision is for foreign policy
because President Obama campaigned on
retrench Minh and then he wrote wrenched
that was not good for America President
Trump campaigned on retrench meant to on
foreign policy and so far he is not
retrench and that's been good for
American foreign policy is here
trenching now I don't know no one knows
and that actually helps the Iranians in
the sense that they want to portray
Trump as an agent of chaos okay in just
a second we'll get to the Trump
administration again sending some mixed
signals on this thing president Trump
looking sort of isolationist on the one
hand and meanwhile acting out on the
other first let's talk about the Wi-Fi
in my house okay so my house happens to
be an older house that means that the
walls are all made of plaster which
means they are very very thick and that
means that the Wi-Fi connection at my
house sucks on one end of the house or
at least it did until I started using
ero getting a good Wi-Fi connection in
every corner of my house it's rough when
you use a single router what you
actually need is a distributed system
that allows strong Wi-Fi to reach
everywhere I mean we couldn't use it in
our kitchen we could use in our bedroom
until it what until it all came came
around this is what offices have had for
years with ero
you can install an enterprise-grade
Wi-Fi system in your home in just a few
minutes simply download the ero app on
your iOS or Android devices it'll walk
you through each step of the process it
is quick it's easy and it's painless
hero+ is designed to provide simple
reliable security that defends all your
home's devices against a growing number
of threats like malware spyware phishing
attacks as well as unsuitable content
the combination of ero with ero Plus
provides complete protection for your
network and all the devices and people
who use them as they connect to the
internet euro plus includes third-party
security apps VPN protection from
encrypted ami password management from
one password anti-virus software from
malwarebytes eros fantastic not only
does it allow me to use my Wi-Fi all
across my house but also it helps
protect me when I am online never worry
about a weak Wi-Fi signal in your house
again get 100 bucks
off the ero base unit and two beacons
package and one year of ero Plus visit
eurocom / Ben that's EE ro comm / Ben
and at checkout enter promo code Ben you
must use the URL to receive the offer
it is erode comm / Ben EE ro comm / Ben
and make Wi-Fi better throughout your
house I'll so make it safer throughout
your house eurocom / Ben go check them
out right now okay so in terms of mixed
signals the president has been issuing
muscular calls he suggested that if they
cross the red line if the if the
Iranians cross a red line there will be
obliteration like you have never seen
before he suggested this over the
weekend not looking for war and if there
is it'll be obliteration like you've
never seen before but I'm not looking to
do that but you can't have a nuclear
weapon you want to talk good otherwise
you can have a bad economy for industry
years not as far as I'm concerned no
preconditions and you'll talk anywhere
it is look you can't have nuclear
weapons and if you want to talk about it
good otherwise you can live in a
shattered economy for a long time to
come okay notice there are a couple of
things that he's saying here that are
really interesting one is he says if you
cross a line an unspecified line then we
will destroy you and then he suggests
that the line is the developments of
nuclear weapons but he doesn't mention
anything about terrorism or about
Iranian aggression in the Gulf of Oman
or any of that sort of stuff which puts
him back on the path to reenter in the
Iran nuclear deal right because if the
idea is all we have to do is stop Iran
from getting a new can just resize into
an agreement where supposedly they
stopped creating nuclear weapons right
which is what Obama was falsely claiming
Senator Tom cotton who's an ally of the
administration a very strong ally of the
administration from Arkansas obviously
man also with military experience who's
on Fox News Sunday he said the big
problem here is we don't have a firm set
of boundaries we need he's saying the
same thing I'm saying here and I think
cotton is correct obviously I think
retaliatory strikes were warranted when
we were talking about foreign vessels on
the high seas I think they were
warranted against an American unmanned
aircraft what I see is Iran steadily
marching up the escalation chain it
started out with threats you went to an
attack on vessels in ports we - an
attack on vessels at sea
now it's an unmanned American aircraft I
fear that if Ron doesn't have a firm set
of boundaries drawn around its behavior
we're going to see an attack on a u.s.
ship or u.s. manned aircraft okay and
he's exactly right you at least have to
make clear to them that if they kill an
American then we are going to blow their
Navy off the map right you have to set
some sort of line just like with a child
okay with my children if my children do
X they get punishment Y that is the way
that foreign policy has to work as well
and here's the thing the Obama
administration was looking to box
president Trump in by creating the
nuclear deal they were boxing in
everybody who opposed Iran's nuclear
weapons program over the long haul it
was originally designed to box in Israel
so Israel wouldn't strike at Iran's
nuclear facilities it was also designed
to box in Trump because the idea was
okay well we've taken the nuclear
weapons thing off the table so what are
you complaining about and Trump said
well what we're complaining about is
Iran using billions of dollars in our
money for terrorism or money we were
holding back from Iran for terrorism
we're concerned about Iran's regional
ambitions and so we're placing sanctions
back on them also we think they're lying
about the nuclear weapons now Iran is
attempting to force Trump back into the
Obama created box they're trying to
suggest that President Trump is the
agent of chaos they're trying to suggest
that the only way out of this morass
right here the only way to avoid war is
for President Trump to basically bribe
them and give them a pathway free to a
nuclear weapon in just a second I'll
show you how Democrats are jumping on
this bandwagon trying to help Iran out
president Trump should not fall for the
trap again if he's a full-on
isolationist believes the United States
should not be in the region he's willing
to abandon that area of the world to the
vicissitudes of the Chinese and the
Russians and the Iranians that's one
thing but I don't think that's what
President Trump wants and I think that's
not what his supporters want either
we'll get to that in just one second
first procrastination really it's a bad
idea in most areas of life but there's
one area of life where actually it's
worked out in your favor because if you
wait long enough sometimes people come
up with some good stuff well that is
true with life insurance now if you're
an adult you need a life insurance I
know you don't want to think about death
it's no fun to think about
plot saying and then doing whatever with
your body instan there's one area where
you do have to think about death and
that is life insurance because what
happens to you after your plots well you
may not care after you die but your
family certainly will so you should go
check out policy genius well your
procrastinating policy genius was
creating a great way to get life
insurance policy genius is the easy way
to shop for insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price
once you apply the PALS
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape if you're in
the ensuring mood which you should be
policy genius can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance but you've been busy
procrastinating check out policy genius
it's the easy way to compare all the top
insurers and find the best value for you
policy genius.com
nobody wants to shop for life insurance
which is why they made it easy for you
go check them out of policy genius com
be an adult make sure your family's
taken care of and they don't throw you
in a pauper's grave go check out policy
genius.com that's policy genius calm
okay so Democrats are jumping onto the
iranian bandwagon Kamala Harris who's
running for president on the Democratic
side and is also a narc she says on Face
the Nation that president from created
the situation so it's not the Iranians
who obviously are creating this chaotic
situation specifically in order to reach
out to people like Kamala Harris so she
will pressure Trump it's Trump who's the
bad guy she is falling right for this
she's doing the work not intentionally
she's not a trader or anything but she
is doing the work of the Iranian
government because the Iranian
government is I think in in quite smart
fashion attempting to create a feeling
of pressure all around president Trump
based on the fact that people don't like
Trump personally and Kamala Harris is
jumping right in doing the work the
Iranians are looking for the left to do
here's Kamala Harris we have to conduct
ourselves in a way that we are smart
about what we do to have one and one
goal only which is ensuring that our
nation is secure and it cannot be the
goal to express one's ego and to engage
in gamesmanship without much serious
regard to the consequence and I think
that's what we've seen in this president
oh well you know it's it's Trump who's
the agent here he's the problem
you got the Washington Post with
headlines like this Trump's erratic
policy moves put national security at
risk
experts warn oh it's the experts now
it's not the Washington Post opinion
they found some experts one of the
beautiful things about the media is you
can always find an expert who's going to
back whatever position you wish to push
right there the I don't see an article
in The Washington Post today Iran seeks
chaos in order to preserve nuclear
option experts warned well they could
have quoted some experts I know some
experts but now those aren't the experts
they want to talk to the New York Times
has a piece today from Susan Rice the
former national secure
advisor to Barack Obama suggesting that
its president Trump's fault that its
president Trump's fault
she says president Trump's process of
ordering and then canceling military
strikes was a mess but he now has an
opening to restart talks on Iran's
nuclear program ah there's the punch
line the punch line members of the Obama
administration doing exactly what Iran
would like them to do trying to push
president Trump back into a bad Iran
nuclear deal that allows her on a
pathway to a bomb and also allows Iran
to pursue its regional ambitions with
American and European cash they're doing
exactly what Iran wants them to do the
only way to fight that is for the
president to take a forthright a a
forthright strong and solid say a solid
stance on what exactly he is willing to
do what our policy is and that's our
policy take it or leave it that's the
way it is and you have Cory Booker this
is this is always amusing to me his Cory
Booker and Democrats claiming the
president Trump can't act on Iran
without coming to Congress let me just
point out that the Iran nuclear deal was
never approved by the majority of the
Senate necessary to approve treaties it
is not in fact a treaty let me point out
that Barack Obama routinely violated his
oath of office by exceeding his
constitutional boundaries now we got
Cory Booker saying well you know
President Trump can't act on Iran
without coming to Congress realistically
speaking we have to the last time we
declared an official war in the United
States it was back in World War two we
haven't had an official war since so
Cory Booker is a little late to this
bandwagon I'm sympathetic by the way to
the idea the president should go to
Congress for foreign policy I mean that
that is the way the Constitution is
supposed to work all I'm pointing out is
the Democrats seems to have had a slight
change of heart about the powers of the
executive branch as soon as the man in
the Oval Office was named Trump not
Obama
I think there's bipartisan group of
senators that spoke pretty clearly last
week that this president cannot take
military action against Iran without
coming to Congress the 2001
authorization for the use of military
force does not cover a military strike
against Iran the Constitution speaks
very clearly on this that he needs to
come to Congress before he engages in
military action that again could have us
tumbling towards chaos and war in that
region okay now do Libya now to Libya or
he wants a full-scale war so cheap
basically not much except getting rid of
a bad guy Qaddafi and replace
with a bunch of terrorists which is
basically what happened in the aftermath
of all of that the legislature ended up
trying to legislate from a boat off the
coast of Libya I don't remember all of
the congressional debate about Libya
good times anyway
in a second we'll get to immigration
we're also we're seeing some mixed
signals and then we'll get to Democrats
who are incredibly radical here's the
truth regardless of what President Trump
does at this point as president if the
Democrats move too far to the left which
they are in the process of doing they're
not winning the election and they are
busily moving in that direction first
cell phone plans bills they're
notoriously confusing and you're
spending a bunch of money on crap you
don't need it is impossible to know what
you are paying for those tiny hidden
fees they're not so tiny when you add
them up no more you need mint Mobile
mint mobile provides the same premium
network coverage that you're used to but
at a fraction of the cost min Mobile
makes it easy to cut your wireless bill
down in just 15 bucks a month every plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talk and
text with mint mobile stop paying for
unlimited data you're never going to use
choose between plans with three eight 12
gigs of 4G LTE data use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan keep your
number along with all your existing
contacts ditch your old wireless bill
start saving right now with mint mobile
instead of spending hundreds of bucks on
data you don't need instead get your new
wireless plan for just fifteen bucks a
month get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mint mobile comm slash
Ben that's mi NT mobile comm slash been
cut your wireless bill to fifteen bucks
a month at mint mobile comm slash Benny
and you don't need that unlimited data
you're not using it right now instead go
to mint mobile comm slash Ben get the
data that you need for 15 bucks a month
mint mobile comm slash Ben that's mint
mobile comm slash Ben okay in just a
second we'll get to immigration
President Trump with ice raids on hold
over the weekend and then we'll get to
the insane radicalism of the Democratic
Party which continues to basically
pledge to hand out everything for free
everything in the universe it's it's
incredible we'll get to that in just one
second first go over to daily wire calm
and subscribe when you do you get all
sorts of goodies for $9.99 a month you
get two additional hours of this show
every day you get the rest of this show
live on video you get an all commercial
free on-demand you also get other shows
we got like the Andrew Clavin show and
the mount wall show and the Michael
Knowles show if you would rather listen
to that I don't know why you'd rather
listen to that and stick a hot poker in
your ear but I guess if you want to you
can
go check all of that out for $9.99 a
month subscription fee also for $99 a
year you can get this the very greatest
in all beverage vessels leftist tears
hot or cold tumblr it is indeed
magnificent and when you get the leftist
chairs hot or cold tumblr the annual
subscription not only is it cheaper than
the monthly subscription you also get
early access to our Sunday's specials
they come out on Saturday
you get extra content behind the paywall
you get to ask me questions in the
mailbag we're constantly updating and
improving and creating more cool stuff
for you behind the paywall so go check
us out right now over at daily we're
calm
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
in other news over the weekend the
President of the United States said that
he would temporarily put deportation
efforts on home remember late last week
he sort of randomly announced on Twitter
that there were gonna be ice raids which
is already kind of weird I mean I
pointed out last week this is the
president who says that you need
strategic unpredictability announcing
raids in advance is probably not a great
strategy if you're then going to do
immigration rates well president Trump
pulled back from that over the weekend
he tweeted out that the at the request
of Democrats I have delayed the illegal
immigration removal process deportation
for two weeks to see if the Democrats
and Republicans can get together and
work out a solutions the asylum and
loophole problems at the southern border
if not deportations start now let me
pause that for just a second that's it
that's a very odd formulation either the
deportations are useful or they are not
useful either they are good or they are
not good the case that he has been
making is that these deportations are
necessary because they're going to be
directed against people who already have
deportation orders in other words people
who have overstayed visas people who
have been adjudicated by a court to be
absconded people who have committed
crimes so saying that you are going to
wait to do anything to see if Democrats
will make a deal with you on the border
is like what would the deal include
keeping these people here it's very
weird like he doesn't have to do this
either do the deportations or don't do
the deportations but to make it
contingent on the Democrats funding the
border is very is a strange policy he
then continued along these lines and
suggested that he was going to to
reinstate this in a couple of weeks
according to the Washington Post
president Trump abruptly suspended his
wide-ranging threat to deport millions
of undocumented immigrants starting on
Sunday demanding the Democrats and
Republicans forge a plan to stand the
record floes of asylum seeking families
across the southern border into the
United States he tweeted out the people
that ice will apprehend have already
been ordered to be deported this is his
old tweet this means they have run from
the law and run from the courts these
are people that are supposed to go back
home to their home country they broke
the law by coming into the country and
now by staying okay then why are we
negotiating over them why aren't we just
deporting them now president Trump
suggests that the deportations are gonna
start in a couple of weeks Nancy Pelosi
wrote that the delay is welcomed she
said families belong together so
Democrats aren't gonna make a deal
instead they're just going to
suggests that this is another act of
cruelty because this is one of the
things that Democrats do on immigration
and it really is awful and that is that
they facilitate cruelty and then they
suggest that the cruelty is the fault of
the Republicans they make the cruelty
happen and then they suggest that it's
the fault of Republicans the best
evidence of this was over the weekend
when there was a tape of a government
lawyer that was going around in which
the government lawyer was telling a
panel of Ninth Circuit judges that it is
safe and sanitary to confine immigrant
children in facilities without soap or
toothbrushes and to make them sleep on
concrete floors under bright lights the
idea here is that the Trump
administration is uniquely cruel to
illegal immigrant children Sara Fabian
the senior attorney at the Department of
Justice online office rather of
immigration litigation was instantly
excoriated online as fate would have it
the clip of her argument went viral at
the same time as a new wave of reports
of brutal and inhumane conditions at
immigration confinement centers nobody
is in favor of any of this stuff
obviously we want better conditions on
the border however it is worth noting
that what exactly this lawyer was
arguing over was an Obama era policy in
other words it was the Obama era policy
not to give these kids these kids
toothbrushes was initiated then and the
Trump administration at the Office of
Legal Counsel the the Department of
Justice they were arguing simply that it
was time to reconsider the so-called
Flores settlement ken white has a piece
over at the Atlantic in which he talks
about this he says the government's safe
and sanitary arguments did not arise
from a new case generated by Trump
administration policies and arose in
1985 during the Reagan administration
when a 15 year old Salvadoran child
named Jenny Lisette Flores was detained
after entering the United States
illegally hoping to escape her country's
vicious Civil War Flores spent two
months at a facility in California
confined with adult strangers in poor
conditions and strip searched regularly
in July 1985 she and three other minors
brought a class action against what was
then called I n s challenging its
policies for the care and confinement of
minors the party settled the lawsuit in
the Flores agreement which required that
the government hold minors in facilities
that are safe and sanitary and that they
be released from confinement without
delay whenever possible over the years
lawyers acting on behalf of minors
protected by Flores have filed numerous
motions asking
to enforce it they argued that confining
minors in these facilities are not safe
and sanitary ultimately a US District
Court judge ruled that the Border Patrol
was violating the Flores agreement
during Obama in 2017 she found that the
CBP failed to provide adequate food and
water to minors
she found the TVB's applications to
provide safe and sanitary conditions
including provided soap dried towel
shower toothbrushes dry clothes and
ordered the Border Patrol to a point to
monitor to bring its facilities into
compliance with Flores G's order put the
government in a technical legal bind
when a federal judge appoints an
official to monitor compliance with an
already existing injunction or agreement
like the Flores Agreement the government
can't immediately appeal the government
can only appeal if the judge modifies
the prior injunction or order so the US
argued that this judge altered the deal
that before it was considered safe and
sanitary now it's no longer considered
safe and sanitary tere so they can
appeal so it's a bad argument right it's
an immoral argument but the litigation
began under the Obama administration the
litigation began there the Trump
administration should be condemned for
the arguments as Ken White but it's
wrong to be thanked at the part to think
the problem can be cured with a
presidential election the administration
has been doing administration's for
twenty years have been doing this sort
of stuff nonetheless Trump gets the
blame because that's the way that this
works meanwhile Democrats refused to
provide the funding that would actually
rectify this situation okay meanwhile
the Democrats get increasingly radical
so they're all competing for attention
at this point Bernie Sanders has now
unleashed a new proposal you'll recall
that Elizabeth Warren created a proposal
that would fund free college education
for all going forward going forward in
time we would tax wealth and then we
would use that money or Wall Street
transactions we'd use that money to fund
college education for everybody this was
always stupid the reason it was stupid
is because disproportionately the people
going to college can afford to go to
college hey they're not lower class
people lower income people rather
they're their folks who are generally
middle to high income or going to
college and so you basically have a
regressive tax that is going to people
who are going to be earning money after
they leave college also if you want to
ensure that the price of college goes
down you don't subsidize it with
taxpayer dollars there are two areas of
American life where prices
consistently gone up since the 1970s one
is student loans the other is healthcare
both are increased in cost because of
government involvement when the
government subsidizes things the costs
go up
you've artificially increased demand by
artificially increasing demands you have
limited the supply still further in
comparison with the demand and that
means that you're going to get increased
prices this is basic econ 101 it's
really stupid it encourages people to go
to college and major in stupid things
that they don't need a major in college
is not for everyone
in fact the path to success for a lot of
smart people it's not just that there
are a bunch of people who go to college
and they don't need to because they're
gonna work with their hands or they're
gonna be or they're gonna be mechanics
or something no there are a lot of smart
people who don't need to go to college
cuz they're smart and they can just get
started in business my business partner
here at daily wired did not graduate
college went to JUCO for two years and
then he dropped out I went to a
community college and then majored in
music he could have stayed a musician or
it could become the partner in this
business and have a lot of money Mark
Zuckerberg didn't finish up at Harvard
Steve Jobs did not finish college okay
they're just a lot of people who don't
need to finish college because college
doesn't do what it was supposed to do in
the first place for a lot of folks there
are people like my wife for whom College
was useful because it finishes with her
becoming a doctor and then there are
people who don't really need to be there
because they're majoring in Poli Sci and
they're gonna get a job teaching history
which they could have done without
having to major in Poli Sci at a
university and incur one hundred and
twenty thousand dollars of debt minimum
well Bernie Sanders is now going even
further than Elizabeth Warren he wants
to propose canceling the entire 1.6
trillion dollars in u.s. student loan
debt which really means three trillion
dollars because he also wants to pay for
everybody's college going forward and
then there's refi of the student loan
debt so presumably you're talking about
probably three trillion dollars in
actual student loan debt so now he wants
it won and while we're at this why not
just relieve everybody's mortgage I'll
just pay for everybody's mortgage all it
would take is taxing everybody at a
higher rate and then we can relieve
everybody's mortgage great plan guys
this is gonna go really really well free
everything for everyone you want to win
over those blue-collar voters in Ohio
talk about relieving student debt for a
bunch of left Coasters who insist on
going to college to major and lesbian
dance theory that's definitely gonna win
over the middle of the country
speaking of such pans ring Elizabeth
Warren has fought back against Bernie
Sanders radicalism now calling for gay
reparations I am not kidding you under
the refund Equality Act according to
Amanda presto giacomo over a Daily wire
same-sex couples would be able to amend
their past taxes readjusting with
jointly filed tax returns and accepting
refunds from the IRS so in other words a
privilege okay I understand the Supreme
Court declared that marriage for
same-sex couples was a right it is not
it's a stupid ruling I don't care
whether same-sex couples get married on
a legal level I'm a libertarian on it
although my libertarianism extends to
the government should not be involved in
marriage period this is a contractual
arrangement between two people I'm not
sure frankly there should be tax
benefits to getting married just on a
libertarian level I think the idea that
the government benefits benefits married
people at the expense of single people
is pretty stupid also it happens not to
be true the fact is that if you tax my
wife's in my combined income we end up
in a higher tax bracket so that's not
it's never been particularly accurate
this idea that getting married provides
you massive tax benefits in any case her
proposal is that because the Supreme
Court has now ruled that same-sex
marriage is a right provided by the
Constitution of the United States which
is an absurd contention that because of
that now we should go back and basically
pay reparations by allowing gay married
couples to file in in in the past retro
actively well they weren't getting
married they weren't married before so
how exactly would you get to that she
said the federal government forced
legally married same-sex couples in
Massachusetts to file as individuals and
pay more in taxes for almost a decade we
need to call that call out that
discrimination make it right and so I
don't even know how you would you would
do this because there are a lot of
couples who didn't get legally married
because they couldn't get legally
married and so oberst fell also how
exactly do you prevent people from
getting legally married simply for the
tax benefits at this point you and your
best friend they I mean there's
literally an Adam Sandler Kevin James
comedy about this it or two guys decide
to get gay married for the tax benefits
this is this is so absurd also if we're
going to point out income differentials
gay couples gay male couples
particularly have a higher joint income
than any other couples in America bison
sticks so now you are paying reparations
to couples that make more money than any
of the other couples by sexual
orientation all of this is ridiculous at
this point frankly Elizabeth Warren
should just come out for reparations
based on you voting for her
basically you vote for Elizabeth Warren
and she will provide you reparations
from somebody else's pocket that's the
direction that we are now moving Cory
Booker meanwhile moving radically - he
says he's not gonna rule out meeting
with Louis Farrakhan because this is
where we are in American life that Louis
Farrakhan an open unrepentant vicious
anti-semitic piece of crap that guy is
still receiving plaudits from people
like Cory Booker because the woke
intersectional crowd insists upon it
here senator Cory Booker saying this you
know I live in Newark so we have famous
mosques 25 we have Nation of Islam there
as mayor I met with lots of folks I've
heard Minister Farrakhan speeches for a
lot of my life so I don't feel like I
need to do that but I'm not one of these
people that says I wouldn't sit down
with anybody hear what they have to say
but I live on a neighborhood where I'm
getting guys on the streets a offering
and selling his works I'm very familiar
with what Minister Louis Farrakhan so
not only is he very familiar he will
still meet with him like the guy who
holds Jews termites this Democratic
Party they take anti-semitism so
seriously inside this Democratic Party
you know calling detention centers at
the borer concentration camps and
internment centers and and making and
making light of meeting with Farrakhan
what delights these folks are this is
not the way to win a national election
so good luck with that time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
Yoram hos Oni who is one of my favorite
philosophers really an interesting dude
he's written a book I've recommended
before called the virtue of nationalism
he has an older book called the
philosophy of Hebrew Scripture that
really is interesting his basic premise
is that there is indeed philosophy in
Hebrew Scripture in the Old Testament as
Christians put it that it is not just a
book of Revelation that we should
approach it as a book with something to
say now I totally agree with this I have
an entire chapter in my book the right
side of history
that is about effectively the philosophy
of Hebrew Scripture yoram hos Oni does
this in a very methodical fashion he
says that there's been this tendency in
philosophy to separate off so-called
revelatory books like the Bible from
philosophy and he points out that if you
read Plato there are times in Plato
where Plato talked about hearing voices
why is that not considered revelatory
Scripture why is it the Parmenides is
talking about receiving inspiration from
on high it's not revelatory he says
that's an artificial distinction that in
the ancient world people very often in
accessing their reason would suggest
that they were speaking with God that
that was sort of godly reason that it
descended upon them so why exactly
aren't we looking at the Hebrew Bible
for moral lessons that can be sucked out
by reason it's a really interesting book
I think your arm is a really interesting
thinker go check out the philosophy of
Hebrew Scripture a little expensive on
Amazon but worth it yoram his own ease
book from 2012 really good stuff okay
time for a bevy of things that I hate
alrighty so Trump was accused last week
last week of rape he was accused last
week of rape by a gossip columnist
she's been four years of gossip
columnist same a Jane Carroll she
accused President Trump of attempting to
rape her
in a changing room at Bergdorf Goodman's
department store in the mid-1990s so her
story was in the middle of a book where
she also accused les Moonves of sexually
assaulting her and a bevy of other men
of sexually assaulting her her store now
listen I think that all allegations of
rape should be taken seriously I do not
however think that all allegations of
rape are equally credible her original
story which was in an interview with New
York magazine
she says the President Trump attacked
her after the pair met in a chance
encounter while shopping at Bergdorf
Goodman in New York City Carol says that
Trump met her she was 52 at the time she
met Trump met her and then urged her to
try on lingerie shopping with him she
acceded to his request he urged her to
try on some lingerie and then she
laughingly implied he should try on the
lingerie and then they went into a
changing room together or into the
changing area he pushed her into a
changing room pinned her arms shore side
and then sexually assaulted her she says
that she then fought off Trump and
escaped and now there are several
questions about this that should be
asked because if this were a rape
prosecution then you would have to ask
the questions
questions would include was there
anybody else around was there any tape
of this apparently there's no tape of it
is there any verifying detail was she
was she physically damaged by this you
know people been comparing a 20 Dru
Broderick Juanita Broderick had a friend
who at the time she showed her torn
panties her bruises like the whole deal
also the timing of the revelation of
this story is a little bit suspicious in
the sense that this lady did not say
anything in 2016 Donald Trump was one of
most famous men in America even in the
1990s she was already a gossip columnist
for a major New York publication so this
is not you know she couldn't speak truth
to power in the 90s she certainly could
she could have said something in 2016
when all of these allegations were
coming about about coming out about
Trump then she didn't she's coming out
with this the week before her book comes
out the week before her book comes out
now very often one of the claims that's
made about this sort of stuff is why
would a woman say this stuff if she has
nothing to gain in many cases that's
true when you're coming out with a book
about it and you waited to say anything
about it until the book comes out you
have that that has to raise some red
flags her behavior during interviews
also raises red flags not all
allegations are equally credible Julie
sweat Nick's allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh were on their face
significantly less credible than the
allegations that were made by Christine
Blasi Ford and even those allegations
had no supporting detail and so you
couldn't end somebody's career or life
based on those allegations so here is eg
in Carole she's now doing interviews on
all the media and she's making very very
weird statements I mean weird statements
so she was asked specifically about why
she was not in favor of prosecuting
president Trump there's no statute of
limitations on rape in New York I
believe so why isn't she in favor of
pushing for prosecution
her response leaves something to be
desired so I just Lawrence I wish I had
said I wish I said I'll tell you my age
if you show me your tax returns so that
is a response to she was at he asked her
age supposedly and she said that she was
in her 50s or something and she says
well I wish I had asked for his tax
returns like doubt that's what's on your
mind right now allegedly he raped you
allegedly he raped you and your talk
about asking for tax returns what and
then
it's weirder would you consider bringing
a rape charge against them for this why
not I would find it disrespectful to the
women who are down on the border who
have been raped around the clock down
there without any protection they're
young women you know and mine was three
minutes I'm a mature woman I could
handle it I can keep going you know my
life has gone on I'm a happy woman okay
I you know what decide for yourselves
decide for yourselves on the credibility
of this person decide for yourself uh
I'm sorry you were according to her she
was forcibly raped in a dressing room
and now she doesn't want to bring
charges she just wants to talk about it
on national TV because she's afraid that
it would distract from people being
raped around the clock on the border
okay I mean I do find it interesting
that this story disappeared basically
from mainstream media over the weekend
then on Friday it was one of the bigger
stories in the country by the time we
finished our radio show and by Monday
not a lot of coverage of this might have
something to do with the fact that this
woman being interviewed does not she
does not recover bility her story does
not recover credibility again rape
allegations should be taken seriously
absent any other evidence other than
this woman's account and in the
president of course has denied it says
he doesn't know her but in the absence
of any other evidence she hasn't brought
forward even the people she spoke to
contemporaneously I don't know how
seriously you can take something like
this given her behavior during I mean
all we have to judge is her behavior
that's all so if we have to judge as the
public the credibility of a story
obviously you have to judge the
credibility of the speaker not all
speakers are equally credible all this
seems fairly logical so maybe it
happened maybe it didn't I don't know
you don't know nobody knows except for
Trump and and this woman all you can do
is judge based on the evidence in front
of you just decide for yourself okay
other things that I hate so everything
is stupid lillian gish one of the more
famous actresses in american history and
the model the very model of a feminist
woman well she has now been removed her
name from a campus theater why well
because she was in DW Griffith's Birth
of a Nation so she starred in the 19th
teen silent film which is a vicious
racist awful film aired by the way by
Woodrow Wilson at the White House
because Woodrow Wilson was the worst
president in American history was a
garbage terrible human being his
students at Bowling Green requested the
change and after a study it was agreed
to change the name now a bunch of
Hollywood stars including James Earl
Jones Helen Mirren and Martin Scorsese
have released an open letter calling for
Bowling Green to retain a Gish's name
she was from Ohio they point out that DW
Griffith's film takes an indefensible
racist approach to the history of the
Civil War and reconstruction but as even
the University admits Lillian was no
racist her work in many films such as
Griffiths own intolerance a dazzling
four-part ovary of world history in
which he plays the symbolic mother
figure rocking the cradle of humanity
and tolerance broken blossoms in
interracial drama the 1955 masterpiece
the night of the hunter in which he
plays a protector of endangered children
the 67 film of Graham Greene's The
Comedians
in which he challenged his Haiti's
dreaded secret police so the ideas if
she played a part in a movie and the
movie is racist therefore they're gonna
remove her name from things that's where
we are is this making America any better
and speaking of things that you wonder
if it makes America any better they're a
bunch of schools that are named after
Robert E Lee now robert e lee's legacy
has come up for a lot of debate recently
i think fairly there's some new accounts
new histories written about robert e lee
talking about how he treated his slaves
specifically how brutal he was and all
of this what he really was whether he
had been kind of whether he'd been
painted with the sepia afterglow because
of the attempt to repaint a level of
heroism in the civil war that didn't
exist in the cause well schools and
named after Robert E Lee are now trying
to figure out how to deal with the fact
that changing the signage cost them a
lot of monies they are now looking to
pick new leads to be named after
unintended consequences everybody now
here's the thing
you could just name all these schools
after Richard Henry Lee who was one of
the founding fathers and the sponsor of
the resolution in Congress that led to
the led to the Declaration of
Independence there's a resolution
suggesting that the colonies hereby
ought to be independent so Richard Henry
Lee an actual founding father a member
of the
Virginia House of Burgesses he was he
presided over the first Confederation
meaning before Congress Continental
Congress was formed you could name him
after Richard Henry Lee but I guess that
wouldn't be woken up I'm not sure I
believe he held slaves so that's not
woke enough so I think Bruce Lee is
probably the best thing to do so just
have a bunch of Bruce Lee schools all
over America which frankly is kind of
hilarious this is where we have moved
okay so we will be back here a little
bit later today with a couple additional
hours of content we will see you then
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey guys over on the Matt Walsh
show representative Ilhan Omar is
accused now of marrying her brother in
order to skirt our immigration laws a
very bizarre weird situation but if it's
true she committed a serious crime
is it true though well well we'll take a
look at the evidence and you decide also
speaking of looking at evidence
president Trump is accused again of
sexual assault there are a lot of things
about this latest accusation that give
me pause cause me to be skeptical but
we'll look at the specifics there look
at the evidence or lack thereof today on
the Matt Walsh show